jibril qui vient vous voir pour un lion
ne meurt jamais j'ai lu le bouquin
franchement il est top non c'est écrit
avec le choeur ces humbles c'est sincère
ça parle de votre maman où ça va
beaucoup de guy roux moi je vous sais
que j'y connais rien en foot de votre
espèce de lien pratiquement paternel
avec guy roux le grand frère qui l'a été
début de vos enfants de votre immense
carrière de footballeur et puis surtout
vous fait des révélations et vous faites
des mea culpa et ça c'est assez rare
pour être souligné c'est pour ça que ce
bouquin est vraiment touchant en plus
vraiment il est super bien écrit fin
c'est au vous avez quand même une vie
passionnante pourra pas se mentir et le
mea culpa c'est celui auprès de raymond
domenech que vous avez fait dans votre
bouquin et que vous avez réitéré hier
dans touche pas à mon sport présentée
par l'excellent estelle denis on va
regarder l'image ça vous dérange pas on
peut reparle après ok on était pas
descendre c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je
m'en veux beaucoup de pas ne pas avoir
eu les couilles on va dire de de réagir
et de sortir du bus parce que pour
l'amour que j'ai pour eux pour l'équipe
de france j'ai l'éclat mais je les dis
beaucoup de fois donc voilà j'aurais dû
au moins pour ça pour moi pour ma
famille et pour la relation qu'on aurait
au moins dû
m'exprimer et dire que c'était une
connerie mais sachez une chose c'est que
je suis pas très fier aujourd'hui et
surtout de vouloir faire ou
des souris
nous avons trouvé ça ça a été
particulièrement émouvant c'est assez
rare en plus que les gens avec autant de
coeur et autant de simplicité
voilà s'excuse vous avez reçu des coups
de fil après comment s'est passé le a
presque c'est pas rien ce que vous avez
fait je sais pas si les gens sont là
mais on se rende compte mais c'est un
gros dossier on va peut-être rappelez
peut-être jean-michel et gilles vous
êtes spécialiste de foot très rapidement
ce qui s'est passé c'est à dire que
voilà ils ont refusé de descendre d'un
bus ils ont fait la grèce qui a choqué
la france entière
et puis voilà des gens comme djibril il
est tellement fier et l'atalante
personnalité qu'on aurait aimé que
certains descendent mais au nom de l'
omerta de la solidarité avec le
capitaine à l'époque ils sont pas
descendus et là enfin il a fait un très
bon mais à cause du miel coup de paris
comment on comment s'est passé le après
mea culpa
oui beaucoup de réactions des gens que
j'étais pas forcément très proche
ah ouais bon envoyer des messages qui
est beau valbuena
je gagne
le plaisir est pour moi c'était c'était
normal et c'était sincère et raymond
c'est une personne que j'adore donc ça
m'a ça m'a vraiment bien sûr cette phase
d'hier elle est à l'image de votre
bouquin vraiment acheté le bouquin
djibril cissé je vous le dis je
n'attendais pas ça j'ai été agréablement
surprise et sartec bienvenue d'être
servis de moi je connais rien au foot
d'accord quand même pas c'était un bon
joueur mais ce que je me demande c'est
quoi l'idée d'avoir mais vos copains du
foot aujourd'hui est ce qui vous appelle
et hier et vous disent ouais tu as
raison tu as parlé en notre nom
ou est-ce que vous êtes un peu tout seul
dans le dans le délire de je m'excuse
j'aurais voulu le faire mais je ne suis
pas je suis pas allé le clown est à go
away membres ont totalement c'est à dire
c'est moi c'est mon avis c'est mon avis
j'ai une relation avec raymond les
autres ont une autre relation vraiment
moi j'ai parlé avec mon coeur avant mon
nom des autres 6 à des réseaux des repas
pourquoi
michael jackson la coupe de mike tyson
je connais vraiment gilles verdez vous
aimez djibril toi que tu réponds pas
vraiment la question est ce ça reçu des
coups de fils par exemple ou insultants
ou menaçant de certains de l'époque
notamment du capitaine patrice evra à
l'époque
est ce que certains on n'est pas dans
touche pas mus par un non mes skis et a
été par exemple menacée verbalement hier
soir une partie par certains joueurs
mais pas de neige pas du tout pas du
tout bon pourquoi qui voyait le maillot
qu'ils fassent pour donner leur avis des
reproches n'ont pas vu la masse du mec
tu vas le menacer allez raconte surtout
s'il ya une question pour ces très
bonnes questions mais j'ai eu le malheur
de la glisse et à caroline ithurbide
dans les loges dans l'émission elle me
l'a dit je me caroline nous avait piqué
la question semble très sûr vous l'avez
vu chez vous on joue vraiment pas ce qui
se passe dans les coulisses des communes
qui pique les questions des copains un
rêve de revenir ce sera vendredi soir
vraiment je reviens de l'altitude
suppléera dit et l'a fourré